so thanks so much for coming here today
uh today we're going to talk about
Pokemon and in the meantime also learn
maybe a little bit about mlops
um so quick show of hands who here has
played Pokemon
ah great that's almost everyone in the
room
um just for the few of you who may not
know in Pokemon it's an RPG it's a game
you pitch your own monsters against
other monsters other Pokemon
um in battle and try to fight till
defend or death or whatever you may play
um
and the Very basics of this game are the
Pokemon types so you have a bunch of
Pokemon each one has a type or maybe two
so for example grass can be super
effective against water water can be
super effective against Fire and Fire
against Grass again and if you want to
be any good at playing Pokemon you need
to at the very least know all of these
types problem is there are a few more
than just the three of them
there's about 18 of them each with
interactions between them
and there are also a lot of Pokemon back
when I was a kid in the 90s there used
to be 150 or 151 to be precise and right
now we're kind of problematic over a
thousand so at that point it just
becomes way too much to learn them all
by heart uh I don't have the time
to go through all of those thousand
Pokemon and learn their type or their
two types
what they do have the time for is to
over engineer a machine learning model
and
learn them for me
so that's what we'll be uh be doing
today
um just a quick bit of background I'm
Rob I'm from Utrecht and Netherlands I
currently work as developer Advocates at
iterative and I'm very much a water
Pokemon type trainer and in a short
while I'll discuss why I chose water at
least for this presentation
so
um the agenda for today will create a
classifier we'll then introduce DVC and
show why and how we're going to use it
and then a little bit of a demo to show
how it actually works
creating a classifier well what do you
do if you want to create a classifier in
this case we start with scraping the
images so we want to get all of Pokemon
images from the Pokemon website so that
we know which ones to classify
and then we create a very basic
convolutional neural network or in my
case you've got your girlfriend to do it
for you because she's better at the
stuff than I am shout out to Alma
and then we start predicting
which of these Pokemon the Sprites we
just scraped is actually a water type so
why did I pick water
class imbalance uh it's Pro with only a
thousand Pokemon it's a bit difficult to
predict all of the classes for all of
Pokemon uh there are by far the most
water Pokemon so it becomes easier for
the data science project
so
as a data scientist I usually tend to
start out with a notebook I just pull up
jupyter notebook type in some code start
looking about and see where we end up so
let's do that this is what the notebook
looked like once I had a working
prototype so we start with some imports
some parameters for setting this is some
maintenance we pre-process some data to
get the image sorry the Pokemon labels
so this is one harder coded each Pokemon
which types do they have then we process
the scraped image data
uh that we got earlier and you can see
that here in the data frame as well
because they now have an image path
which we can boot into the model
um and at the end of the uh the entire
notebook we can put in an image this mod
cap here is actually water Pokemon our
model will provide a prediction
so 0.87 there's probably a water Pokemon
and indeed Mudkip is water Pokemon for
those who are very familiar with Pokemon
I think it's also ground Pokemon or
maybe only
only its evolution is a ground Pokemon
okay so our model is working perfectly
here very happy about that
and as you can see we can pull up a
confusion Matrix we've got a few false
positives a few false negatives but by
and large our model is doing pretty good
so we're finally ready to play some
Pokemon right
no because a new Pokemon game just got
announced it was released uh last month
I think to mixed reviews if I'm putting
it nicely but Pokemon scarlet and violet
got introduced and now our entire data
set which we use to train the uh the
model it's it's yeah it's outdated
so what can that entail well we're
getting a new data set with new Pokemon
with New Image Sprites that might
introduce some derivative models it
might affect our performance we don't
know that yet and we may even need to
retrain our model
sounds familiar yet
hopefully yeah as data scientists the
work we do is never stagnant we can
create a model and we can put it into
production and a week from now the
entire world may change I think we saw
it with all the predictive models when
covet struck stuff changes the world
around changes and we need to adapt
so I think in an earlier talk we saw the
xkcd comic where you just start
shuffling your pile of data until the
right results start coming out uh with a
little bit of a nicer World I'd like to
call that experimentation uh that's a
process we have to adapt to the changing
world
but the problem with experimentation at
least if you start doing it in a
notebook is that it's very hard to keep
track of which stuff you're
experimenting with
so we may change the input data we use
the trainer model we can change some
hyper parameters and parameters some
class weights maybe we may even be
interested in becoming a different kind
of strainer for this presentation
and all of this stuff gets real Mucky
real fast
so another show of hands
um
who here has experimented and kept track
of their input settings by writing on a
piece of paper or if you're very
Advanced by writing an Excel sheet
yeah
notepad also good
um so if I speak for myself this always
goes goes awfully awful it gets Mucky uh
oh another thing we can change so just
by that we multiplied our number of
experiments by five
um it becomes difficult to track and
soon if you're trying to reconstruct a
model to reconstruct an experiment it
becomes a game of who's that Pokemon or
what is that model what were the
parameters we chose what were the data
we put into it what were the
um uh the code as it was at that point
what was the resulting model the
artifacts had produced plots
all of it is separated and uh you you
can't find all of this together anymore
so
for
we're going there uh
you don't or you're not no longer able
to reproduce your model and if we want
to properly experiment if we want to run
those experiments and be able to refer
to them we need to go for full
reproducibility now for code if you've
got a software engineering background
you may know that this is solved problem
right you just use git you use git repo
you go to GitHub gitlab if you're using
it and you can look up the entire
history of your code
but we don't do this for data sets we
can't do this for model files they're
too large to be important so what if we
could get that that that very nice git
based approach but use it for our data
sets and for our models
and for that we want to capture each
experiment as the combination of three
separate things the the data that went
into model training the code that we use
to model train and the parameters at a
given point in time and we can do that
we use get for code and for the
parameters everything that's text based
and we use DVC and this is where I
launched into sales pitch so the full
disclosure is I work for iterative as
you saw earlier uh iterative creates VPC
the good news is I'm not trying to sell
you anything because DVC is free in open
source to use
um so I already discussed a little bit
the why for DPC we want to be able to uh
track a version our experiments and for
that we need to also track and version
our larger data sets our models
alongside git now let's see how DVC can
help us do that
divc consists of three major components
data Version Control is namesake the
pipelines that we use for our model
training and experiment tracking
if we start with first one that's uh
probably the one the most of you will
know if you have heard of USD or used
DVC in the past we have a git repo this
is what might look like so we start at
the bottom and you've got your commits
on successful order we've got a branch
here and in a branch we have a given
data set of Pokemon so these are Pokemon
Sprites that we are using but we can't
necessarily store those price in the git
repo because there are image files
so what do we do we got DFC we run DVC
and net and DVC replaces the image files
themselves with a metadata file
and that metadata file stack space so it
can easily be tracked by git
then we have the DVC cache which does
include your image again there are
physical images on your hard drive and
DVC knows how to tie the metadata files
to those locations in your DVC cache and
the great thing about this is that DVC
doesn't duplicate your data so for
example if we have new commit which you
can see here because we changed the uh
typeface something has changed our data
set has changed here as well because now
we're using Charizard instead of omastar
in this new data set and if you see it
doesn't duplicate the other two that are
still in there so Slowbro and uh fix
Rebel weeping Bell what's his name again
um so straight away we have a DFC cache
we don't need to duplicate our data for
multiple experiments and we can track
given data sets to given experiments in
our get commit history and if you want
to get really fancy just like you
usually don't run gits only on your
local computer you can also mirror your
DVC cache to someone else's PC which may
be in S3 buckets or something on Azure
can even be Google Drive we can we can
upload this to the cloud
so that's the basic data versioning then
we can take it up a notch and go for
Pipelines
so
um
this may seem familiar if you know Dax
directed a cyclical graphs you have one
thing and it's uh once the first stage
has completed we go to the next one and
we don't it's it's one way streets we
only go one way so this reflects the
notebook I showed earlier we first have
a data pre-processing stage we have the
data loading stage we then do some model
training and finally we start predicting
or evaluating and each of these stages
produces outputs so for example the
pre-processing stage in this case we get
a data set with labels and data set of
images
and that's all nice and good so we have
the output struct but then those outputs
are also inputs for the next stages so
the data load stage will only kick off
once DVC detects that the data set
labels and the data set images has been
generated
um
with that pipeline let me show one more
time we can now run our entire notebook
or rather the code that we copied from
our notebook into our python modules and
make sure that we get everything
reproducible and not only the code not
only the parameters but our data and
resulting models as well
and now we can finally start
experimenting or the messing about in
the pile of data and so we get the
results that we want
so what does that look like this is our
pipeline again so in the middle we have
our pipeline we have to find that the
Scout and dvc.jaml file I will share
this a little bit later
um and our inputs are to go to data and
the parameters
and the outputs that this process
produces are model plots and metrics
plus any other artifacts that you may
generate if you still choose
and we can Define one pipeline run of
this
we can version each of these components
with either get or with DVC so generally
you'd go for git for text-based files
and if it's something larger like an
image data set you probably want to go
over to DPC
and each of these pipeline runs
corresponds with a git commit or an
experiment in this case and the good
thing or the nice thing about this is
that at any point we want we can go back
to another commit as you can see there
up top
and just do get checkout then leave C
checkout and you get that very
experiment that we read earlier a while
back at a conference I was talking to a
German guy and he used to work for a
bank and he was asked hey we saw this
very funny thing going on so do you
remember that one model that we built
five years ago
um yeah there are some unexpected
results and we now need you to find out
which data went into training it which
data was used in prediction uh why it's
making these kinds of predictions that
we don't really want
um yeah also we need a fast
they spend about two weeks trying to
reproduce that model with an entire team
and in certain Fields this auditability
is kind of important so you can save a
lot of time simply by tracking
everything in a git-based approach and
then being able to do get checkout in
the C checkout in this case
so let's zoom out to the real world for
a little bit uh because thus far I've
been talking about Pokemon it was nice
to get you into the room but usually we
don't get to play around with Pokemon uh
for our talks
or for talks I can do whatever I want
but in as a data scientist working in a
grown-up pills or in grown-up profession
you usually are worried about Healthcare
or about Finance or infrastructure
um so this approach that I just
described how is it interesting to us as
professionals as data scientists
well as I mentioned in healthcare you
may be interested in knowing which
patient data went into training what
kind of model and it may be very
important to be able to reproduce
precisely that experiment same goes for
finance you want to know why someone got
a loan or I used to work for a fraud
detection team by someone someone's
order was marked as possibly fraudulent
um so that traceability and auditability
is a key concept of this philosophy and
then also collaboration uh can be very
important uh I don't know if you've ever
collaborated in data science team it's
very easy to get something working on
your environment or in your computer and
then move it over to a colleague of
yours or or their laptop and as soon as
you try to run it you get a bunch of
errors and dependency is missing
um bundling all of this together and
saying just give me that commit allows
for Effective collaboration
that's the philosophy behind this
get-based approach to data science and
experimentation now let's see how that
actually works in practice this is where
I'm taking you out of notebooks for a
little bit because a lot of this is what
we Define as code
and we generally do so in yaml files
so here you can see my IDE I'm using vs
code and I have split up the notebook
and the stages we defined earlier which
would just run subsequently into
separate python modules it's just copy
paste work and appended Dot by at the
end of the file name
and from there on out you can run these
from your command line and it produces
uh outputs so for example the train.pi
here this is precisely the stuff I also
had in my notebook I copy pasted it here
and at the end we save the estimator
that we train
um and then in the DVC the yaml file we
Define these modules as stages in our
pipeline so for example this is just the
command that we execute this can be
anything that you want as long as a wood
running or CLI we Define outputs
dependencies and parameters and the
params are the find in your browser yaml
file where they're automatically
detected so for example here I change
the number of epochs to do a newer
experiment and the batch size and for
good measure also the learning rates I'm
just messing about here and with one
single command we can kick off the
entire pipeline
run a new experiment and see how the
results hold up so if you look here it
Scrolls by a little fast but the first
two
the first two stages they didn't change
so it might as well skip them I mean we
have cached the output we can just reuse
whatever we have going on because if
you're not using your uh or changing
your input data then you're also not
wanting to rerun the first few stages
we did on model training uh it takes a
little while so might as well grab a sip
of water and in the end we end up with a
new experiment that we can evaluate
um so how do we evaluate this model
these models
um we can run this from our CLI and show
the experiment table that we supervised
we can also
um let's see what we get here yeah we
can also use the DVC extension for
visual studio code which provides a nice
graphical interface for this so here you
see a bunch of experiments
each with changing parameters and among
these the experiments that I just ran
with update accuracy and then you can
see the top one there it performs quite
well we're quite happy with these
results so from there on out we can take
this experiment and create a new Branch
from it which will automatically
be incorporated into your get repo
um here's where I run a new experiments
or for example this generation I'm
interested in becoming a dragon trainer
and in this case the first few stages do
change so now it needs to do the data
pre-processing again and in the end it
will also end up there for comparison
um and to see which one of these
experiments work nicely
so to provide a little bit of recap I
see I'm doing good in time we train a
model to predict whether a Pokemon a
given Pokemon or a Pokemon Sprite was a
water type Pokemon so for example Mudkip
is indeed a water Pokemon
and
we had an experimentation based approach
to that we want to keep messing about
and we want to keep track of our
experience so that we don't end up with
sticky notes Excel sheets and the need
to reproduce uh something four years
down the line uh just now earlier I was
uh in a talk about code archeology we
kind of want to prevent that if we can
and if you see and get provides a good
approach for that
um because as the world changes uh so
sure our model so should the stuff that
we do with the data that changes as a
result of the ever-evolving world around
us
um and those model changes we achieved
that through experimentation and then
messing about in the pile of data and
hoping the right stuff comes out
if we ever want to do experimentation in
a proper way we need our experiments to
be reproducible and for that that's
where this entire bundling comes
together and that's something we can't
just do with get we need another tool
for that and that's it if you see at
least that's what I'm proposing use as a
tool for that
um all of this together takes us away as
a data science maybe the Alchemists of
your when we're just messing about and
not documenting our results and our
findings and then taking those findings
that we have properly documenting them
being or ensuring that other people can
take those findings and continue our
work for us and also making sure that we
can always get back to something that we
did a few comments ago
um thank you for your attention
um if you are interested in learning
more I do have a few further resources
the project that just described is
available as a GitHub repo
um I also have a blog post all of this
is on iterative.ai where I take the uh
the original prototype in a Jupiter
notebook then read that notebook so that
you can execute it from your CLI and use
that as an experiment tracking or
experimentation platform and a follow-up
post will take that approach and also
properly split up
the entire notebook so that we have the
stages separately defined
um we're also at the booth so come chat
us up uh if you're interested about
learning more
and some acknowledgments where you will
be able to find insulate later on thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
now for some questions
any questions
on the
are you sure ready
okay first of all thank you for your
presentation it was very interesting um
I have a question how easy it is to
scale it to a kubernetes cluster or AWS
to train a lot of models on a lot of
gpus
right
um so the DFC part that doesn't actually
uh do your model training for you it
defines a pipeline and it executes the
commands we do have other tools in our
ecosystem so I don't want to devolve
into sales page but iterative provides a
number of Open Source tools that
together allow you to do your ammo labs
um and another of a product CML
um would definitely help you do that
um that's basically cicd for your
machine learning so you can use your
GitHub actions for example uh to from to
run a script every time a new merch
comes in or commits or every other
Tuesday or not
um and then provision whatever Cloud
instance you want and do your model
training for it
we can talk about that a little bit
later sure okay thanks
yeah
can I just ask him for one second sorry
so if you have a question
Rob is gonna throw you a pair of gloves
oh I'm doing it yes you better come up
with some if you want some nice gloves
from iterative yeah yeah they were
supposed to be in the goodie bags but
they only arrived just now so I don't
okay pass it on any other questions for
Rob
yeah if you will help with this thanks
I'm going for the gloves uh my question
is what is the difference between this
framework and using git lfs for storing
your data sets yeah that's uh one uh a
question I I get a lot
um so uh get lfs has it has some
downsides with regards to caching I
think I haven't used lfs excessively in
the past for one lfs doesn't provide the
experimentation and the the pipelining
functions and it's also a little bit
more restrictive with regards to what
you can put in it if I recall correctly
um
yeah come check us up at the booth and
uh we can dive into this further I've
got a few colleagues who are more
proficient than that than I am
sorry here
over here it's gonna be there first oh
over there got it
hello
um
is my understanding correct that if you
want to store data set attached to an
experiment it's going to be a good
commit
sorry come again if you want every
experiment for which you want to store
the data for
is that going to be a git commit
um so what you get commit is to metadata
file
um that deepsea creates for you yeah
um and the data itself that's what you
can put in whatever you're using for
your story yes okay so however we would
do hundreds of experiments while
training a model so I would have
hundreds of gate commits like one per
experiment uh yeah so in the background
uh each experiment is sort of a commit
but not really uh I think that there's a
technical term for them and you can
promote them to True commits
um and then create a branch from there
or just commit them to your development
branches you're already working on but
you don't need to keep track of each and
every experiment you run okay thanks
I had a question here we go
thanks for the talk
um
you showed the visualization tool for vs
codes if you significantly change the
parameters that you feed into the model
maybe you change from a newer Network to
SG boost or something like that how does
that show up in the visualization it's
all fine because they look quite tabular
right I don't think I can easily show it
here but
um you have a drop down where you can
select which columns you want to show up
so if those change for an experiment or
for a new Branch for example you can
disable them or re-enable them and they
can show up empty as well if they don't
have the right data there I think he
also saw that in this in this instance
anyone else
hi hi a small question about the cash uh
did I get this correctly that the files
in the cache are stored with something
like an md5 hash or something as a file
name like a hash is a file name yeah nd5
in this case although I think that's Up
For Debate currently somewhere in a
second okay yeah so uh you've you've got
an image Pokemon Sprites it generates a
hash and that hash is reflected in the
metadata file that gets stored for you
okay and my question is have you heard
or are you aware or is there an official
ipfs connector for the cache uh I'm not
sure to be honest
again we can discuss up with your uh
maybe cool let's check later thanks
we have question in the front row
it's quieted down a little bit more with
the uh yeah claws being unpacked yeah
everyone has gloves now by the way
hands up if you don't
okay put up your cold empty hands
great talk I have a highly technical
question for you oh dear sorry it's so
little red yeah do you like mudkips
um honestly I pitched that it was a
water type trainer
I've been a fire type trainer since
since my youth so the first uh
uh yeah I'm very sorry to disappoint you
Charmander yeah I think the first game I
played was actually Pokemon Sapphire so
that was Torchic for me
okay okay okay we're done here
any other questions
yeah
oh there we go there we go
all right so thanks for the the talker
question regarding DVC commits do you
also have the notion of committers uh
when I'm looking at a code base with Git
I like to you know point fingers using
stuff like that it's blame yeah for sure
do you have the same thing with DVC or
not
yeah so
um uh yes because if I do something and
I get pushed then I'm the author of The
commit
um and because DVC is uh or the data
versioning done by DVC is very much tied
to your get commit history that's
reflected there as well
foreign
that's an easy one yeah hi thanks for
the talk and is there a possibility of
integrating
um
data versioning tools with uh the
concept of a feature store
um so this is something that we are
working on
um
it's it's in progress uh right now DPC
is a by and large file based so that's
also a huge case that would uh
would recommend it for
um but yeah there are our ecosystem of
tools is ever evolving
um so if you're interested in seeing
that uh please join our GitHub join our
Discord and get get into the discussion
and because we're very much uh yeah
Community Driven in our development so
if we know that the need is out there uh
we may yet build it
okay cool thanks
ah there is another question in the
front row are you
uh I haven't actually played it yet so I
haven't also had the need to uh uh to
update it
but did you see the starters are you
picking the fire one or the water one oh
yeah okay
fair enough
um the duck does look nice
oh yeah
no but I don't want to spoil myself
first straight away it's about the
exploration
any other questions
I went all the way in the back to make
me walk again or
hey like I said you get more steps yeah
all right I think uh we can go
on a break but before that please
another round of applause for Rob
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you and I do want to know where
did you
how did you get your character made uh
commissions only Fiverr you had a
commission right nice